citizens of the reject Nation it is time
we're gonna do this one more time Greg
where are you going we are going to head
to death's Corner today Roxy it's our
final destination two this should be
final destination again two final two
destinations oh see pitched that it's
really really good if you guys want to
take the journey with us
my pun game is incredible it is then
please do don't forget to like subscribe
all that good stuff I hear that this one
might even be better than the first one
I know literally nothing about it yeah I
didn't know anything about it you told
me it was a comedy so it was it was
hilarious yes there was a lot of
physical comedy involved in it thank you
so much to prepper for editing this
video and of course if you want to see
more then sync up with us over on
patreon go to patreon.com the real
rejects that's it that's it I was
confident she's not a patron obviously I
should be I support the world girls
do you no you don't she has no idea in
theory you do in theory and then you
guys get the full length video watch
along with us over on patreon yeah yeah
we did it yeah we nailed it excited two
two final destination two with you
poop poop
[Music]
shout out to one of the producers for
checking us out the last time appreciate
that oh yeah that was really kind thank
you tomorrow marks the one year
anniversary since valet Air flight 180
exploded and crashed shortly after
takeoff from JFK Airport that's the last
movie
good memories
died soon thereafter in a series of
mysterious and bizarre accidents they're
an indication that there are more
Sinister events taking place yeah evil
most people say Supernatural because
they think I'm talking about ghosts and
witches and stuff like that well here's
your chance to set the record straight
but she's doing drugs okay well well how
do you think that oh never mind she's
trying to get I thought she had like
she's snorting spiders yeah I thought
she had something in her arm for a
second
and
some people call us
okay party Dayton Beach
so I prefer to call it death itself
reference to road trip is this one going
to be an actual Road Trip movie I don't
know but Tony Todd's coming back
apparently yes and that's what I want
people to understand the death has this
Grand Design that we all fit into that
has nothing to do with the elements
he basically screwed up death's plan and
and that's what I'm trying to warn
people about oh my God it's like
reaching the world yeah this concept
this is like the uaps yes yes
so you should be more open-minded you
say Kimberly
yeah who is calling her so-called
everyday coincidences what if you could
do something about peace are you
listening to yourself I like this this
is some cool World building here the
only way to survive is to look beneath
the visible world it's striking a
different Aura none of them are blinking
that's what I mean there's more of this
hypnotic Flair Roxanne Kimberly you sure
you've got everything credit cards cell
phone AAA card yeah it's Daytona the
main character is a woman this time
condoms
all right my girl
I'm getting horny I would not let my
daughter be friends with this girl she's
a full-blown adult what are you gonna do
I would not allow it this is why America
has standards I've never seen either of
these women before I kind of feel like
they're not gonna make it out it's just
because we're starting with them do you
think she's the lead uh uh no no you're
right up period
hi way to hell I forgot how the tone of
Highway to Hell goes
I wasn't going to question
Kimmy first you're driving sorry
whoa that's a loud sound
[Applause]
was the guy always in the car we're
gonna get
like oh dude already
I like this group of friends doing the
same thing that they did on the plane
were really hyper focusing on individual
sounds and images the blood the bus
good observations
[Laughter]
oh my God are you serious death are you
next so that's wild are you making me a
joke right now no I really don't I have
no idea what happens in this movie
isn't that wild did you see that I know
am I dead hey Kimberly it's dead
um hey what's up I'm really proud of
that one
yeah yeah uh
why is the transmission fluid oh my God
this movie's so much better than the
last one
there's a cop minus from the right lane
now
not suspicious at all put it out okay
Dan put that thing out wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait just smoke
it as fast as possible
you're gonna still smoke it oh
wow oh what the hell no just wait not
you
what is going on where's the truck that
was in front of them oh
oh no
we know these this franchise isn't
afraid to kill babies nope
those things are definitely coming off
the truck 100 that's why I said where is
that truck those logs are about to be
lagging
behind
this is one of my biggest fears so what
happened in the movie Under the cave
diving the spelunking movie that we
watched The Descent yep that impaled
oh the little boy's warning you who are
these freaks on the road I don't know I
drive next to some freaks too and
sometimes I am the freak
oh
honey you're dead
that pretty face gonna get ruined
there's a colorful cast of characters on
the freeway today yeah
I can't believe that cop hasn't pulled
anybody over yet stadie you call him
that here nah Sadie it's a Boston thing
oh drugs so much you saw that too I know
I feel this movie
I'm vibing I'm freaked by you YouTube
none of the drugs are real it is fake
oh no login
s be lagging ah
bummer bummer
oh my goodness
[Applause]
this is so crazy gnarly
practical damage here
[Applause]
but maybe like in the last movie maybe
she's just seeing all this and maybe
yeah that's what I'm thinking
that's happened to me with a water
bottle before
[Applause]
wow dude
the effects here are amazing
unbelievable
[Applause]
[__] is just blowing up We Didn't Start
the fight see I'm gonna try to do what
you did Fall Out Boy no oh
[Music]
burn feel death
wow it is like hell is coming for them
why is that truck not stopping
oh easy kidney first you're driving
wow it started way back then and there
huh Bravo I Gotta Give it up man that
was a great sequence that was a great
sequence they really nailed that man I
really love how they blew all that [__]
up that was awesome that was really good
we're all gonna die I just saw it all
right that's it my turn to drive no I'm
serious she looks like uh a Gilmore girl
and she's likely to believe it too
because she was listening to the news
thing as well yeah yeah
[Music]
God I am so impressed with myself right
now I'm freaked out by you no you should
be
I miss I'd like you to please step out
of the vehicle she's got a good 10
minutes before that happens so she's
gotta keep talking I know
usually we could drive around I have a
delivery but you need to get back into
your vehicles
now
does he believe her
buddy calm down
enemy
[Laughter]
Kimberly what's going on
[Music]
180 just like the plane
[Applause]
oh
that
was unexpected
okay so she stays I was gonna say we
can't not know any of them
oh so I guess these are the two main
characters Maybe
but we gotta find our guy too right he's
got to be back in this our guy from
Misawa yeah I feel like he's dead listen
I know you've gone over all this with
Detective subi subie Dooby Doo
like I was there
because they don't blame her like they
blamed Sawa she's a woman you feel
softer for her you know
couldn't have possibly done it look I
know this sounds crazy but you guys all
heard about flight 180 right yeah
my premonition was just like his ooh
premonition
exactly you had a dream about a plane
blowing up so he got all his buddies off
the plane and then the thing blew up
just like in his dream yeah but did you
hear what happened after
oh this guy's cool death itself hunting
each one down oh he's a Storyteller oh
dead oh there was one Survivor clear
Rivers is in a padded room at the Stony
Brook institution she lived and we
learned that her name is not Claire it
is clear really comments told us that
I'll go now where's the period blood
yeah there should be a trail
how can you possibly determine the trail
of that of who would die next maybe they
don't know it's all random or maybe you
would just think it's whose car was in
line in order or something that's not
fun that's boring you're nothing no your
suggestions no wonder you didn't write
Final Destination oh oh you know I
suddenly want to buy a Mac product this
is right when PC was still doing great
things so yeah
dude this guy lives like trash it's like
it doesn't feel like fate as much as it
feels like clean your apartment and
don't die maybe but he drove a sick car
it was posturing I bet he gets a lot of
people yes just spaghetti in his family
this guy's a certified hoarder yeah but
it smells in there oh oh
my God I'm glad he's gonna die like
why'd you keep it if you were gonna just
do that
hey e
what does that mean I don't know what it
says what's up e
the H fell off
hey hey hey
or I all right
oh maybe hit something's gonna happen to
his eyes that might be it yeah
okay across
nipple ring that's hot and listen I
heard about your lottery win let's hook
up call me
yeah oh so he's just blowing all his
money let's get all lottery winners do
have you looked into that
huh lottery winners like end up in a
it's horrible it happens to them no no
no ah no I don't wanna
no it's not gonna turn on it's not going
to turn on it's cannot turn on we can't
lose his hand first oh go go after
yourself do not do this to me grease it
up put some soap in there
I don't want to watch
I think it's gonna happen
no way no do not throw that on there are
you dumb
oh my God
what was your plan there bro this is
drastically escalated oh he's gonna cut
his own hand off this is like the Saw
movies he's literally gonna cut his own
hand off wow wow he's got to survive
he's he's four he's gonna have to do it
oh thank God
that's one of those
break the window
oh the spaghetti
he's gonna slip on the spaghetti that's
what I think he's gonna do oh my God
that's amazing
that's out fine but he slips on the
spaghetti that will be hilarious death
by his own spaghetti slippage
slip on the spaghetti
[Music]
oh okay
Jesus Christ move move oh
[Music]
that was legit violent
ah horror sequels he always gonna amp up
that door that's very good that was
wacky as hell
that was so fun who is Alex Browning
Alex from the last movie which one was
that Devin Sawa oh
no no that's Alex
don't argue an idiot I said that to you
like so condescendingly too I'm like
come on Roxy you know who Alex was
[Music]
he looks right at the camera I want to
know what happened with Sawa maybe he's
living in secret I think that okay
falling brick takes life of
falling falling brick
uh if you're free of a falling brick
okay
clear River see a brick early that's
what took him out a brick no but it said
although the death has yet to and I
think it I feel like maybe we're still
not sure if he's dead or not yeah he's
been in the Warwick for a while though
this feels like when like an 80s slasher
movie tone with like
the drugs and the The Whimsy
while trying to escape a fire in his
I think so far this movie is having a
lot more fun I still waiting to see if I
I kind of like the characters a bit more
in the first one
you know well they're but there were a
couple of friends yeah not friends so
I'm waiting to see how this progresses
though he's reading Stephen King
and then tomorrow it's after the dentist
to love
because it's important go to the dentist
get your teeth cleaned every six months
at least guys
you don't want to deal with a nightmare
clowns oh my God we're gonna kill the
kid who are you calling a kid the little
boy little boy the little boy who just
got tucked into bed like he is older
than that no he's a he's a teenager he
ain't talked in the bed
oh creepy
skeleton creepy crawler it's a Reaper
Grim Reaper exactly that's a Reaper yeah
reaping the souls I know
I'm sorry
I'll keep all this in the video prepper
[Music]
so funny that they decided to name her
clear I feel like it fits her name with
the empathetic nature she had
get directions to New York where did we
establish we were I have no idea Jersey
I mean the obviously shot the [__] in
Canada why you say that it looks like
Canada I'm gonna look it up when this
movie's done I bet you're right yeah
foreign
movies that go to psychiatric places
they're always so scary
this is Arkham Asylum you're right so
they always treat it like their lack of
sensitivity to people with mental health
struggles but there are some dangerous
people in these spots how many people
died in a freak accident last night what
if the other people are in danger too
well if you put them on the list they're
already dead whisper list
death's list duh the survivors of flight
180. died in the exact order they were
originally meant to die in the plane
crash how could you figure out that
order though you said that someone else
died last night that means someone must
have intervened I officer Burke put me
away from the crash to kill my friend
once the others are dead it'll come back
for you how is she not dead because Saul
I must have died must have skipped her
you said that you die in the order
you're originally meant to but my
friends died last in my premonition not
first
wait death is mixing [__] up the guy in
the beer took everything on the road
well don't ignore it recognizing those
signs usually means the difference
between life and death yeah I think
Claire is going to die in this movie but
you beat it
take a look around what did I beat
Kimberly if you were smart you'd save
yourself and just forget about the
others how can you say that you have a
responsibility
[Laughter]
how does she responsibility why
and this is what happened to Alex when I
was responsible for him
a brick I feel like you faked it it's a
crappy way to go it's just a brick I
don't believe it everyone gets like a
crazy Contraption of a tip I think it's
a death was like [__] I'm just gonna
drop it some brick on it because you're
too damn bitter and selfish to help any
other person why are you so mean she
didn't do anything to you we gotta Speed
the movie up that's why
what
I like all of a sudden I hate her
Kimberly you're the worst be nice to
clear
she's lost everybody well she thinks
clear would have the answers for some
reason I don't see how Tony Todd would
have the answer yeah clearly you should
send her to Tony it's funny like the
first one felt like a 2000s movie this
feels like an earlier ERA this feels
like more 80s I've been getting calls
all morning from everyone who was on the
on-ramp you believe all this death stuff
no I didn't until last year when I was
dispatched to clean up one of the flight
180 survivors
thank you
if clears right about the order then uh
Nora and Tim are going to be attacked by
pigeons I'm not following you they're
next on desk list but isn't it go
backwards with you uh uh yeah that is
the newly established rules
poor clear she's gonna leave and you're
right she's gonna die now I think she's
not gonna die though because she's the
only remaining member in the franchise
she's dead this movie I feel like scream
rolls you got to keep somebody alive
right this movie's breaking the rules
but then Devin saw was actually alive
yeah
imagine her death by paper cuts
like that's gold that's funny we missed
you in here we got hung up by that
accident on Route 23. your mom says
you've been having some pain oh no where
are the pigeons do you have a fish tank
growing up
nah
oh all the water is gonna come out of
the fish the waters back the elements
are back yo it's all about the elements
baby the elements man
to be filled
oh oh no how many times am I gonna have
to replace those goddamn Windows damn
that's a strong pigeon how many times
have you already replaced them oh no oh
no oh no Greg I really don't like out of
everything the regular Dental [__]
because I know I know it's gonna happen
I know what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen
what's gonna happen
would you rather just have a laughing
gas
you'll be awake a little groggy but
you're gonna be able to move much
you're not gonna be able to move much oh
no oh he's dead he's way dead
of all of the things so far this is the
toughest for me
I actually can't watch
oh stop stop
anyway what's happening
no no no
are they gonna get there and save them
how are those pigeons strong enough to
pierce the window
[Music]
no oxygen all nitrous they can't go that
gory on a little kid hey what's up with
those fish they're not real fish I think
it's gonna fall in his mouth he's gonna
choke to death stop stop stop stop stop
right I don't know I can't see
no you can't move poor guy that's so
horrible help help
that's hilarious
push user oh you can't use his tongue
[Music]
that's probably like not again well I
literally just drooled
very stressed out and I forgot to
swallow my saliva
no no
[Music]
oh
you just got
I'm so happy right now this is so funny
okay so she gets skipped because he
interfered
that was
crazy
the deaths are so brutal everyone's not
coming
or something no but she's next she's not
next she gets skipped she got saved the
rules are all out the window you know a
horror movie's serious when they kill
off a kid a child actor YouTube you
gotta clarify these things because
their AIS are weird I know you didn't
ask for any of this but I don't think
you have any to quit either
let's go kick death's ass you owe her an
apology we're like an hour in and I
still feel like I don't really know
these guys trying to remember who's like
you know
but man I'll tell you that that stuff is
really fun in this movie this guy
this guy's anyway you seem to know a
hell of a lot more about death than he
ever told
wow is this what the outside of his
place looked like in the last one but
like what what we never really
established who Tony Todd I mean he
works in a more so he's like so in tune
with death
yeah it really amped up like the pulpy
horror zest this time around it's fun
man
look at these it's just like a straight
up spook Fest this looks like a
Disneyland ride
oh my God emerge from it
so nonchalant
we drove a long way to get here so if
you happen to know how to stop death
there are no Escape
you told me death has a distinct design
but Alex and I cheated death not once
but dozens of times
I'll watch that is that a rip it out
yeah
I don't want to watch that
oh thank God we didn't see it why did he
have to do it like that because he is
so cool because he's cremating him it's
just I don't get why Kimberly is mad at
clear I don't get like clear as mad at
Tony uh you know sometimes you just
throw in the emotion of anger to enhance
a scene only New Life
defeat death
what the hell does that mean get
pregnant or you gotta sacrifice someone
the introduction of life that was not
meant to be
That Couldn't validate the list forced
death
Start Anew or get pregnant you might be
right
how do you know my
mom
he's like the weirdest addition to this
movie that's so great because it's him
but also what oh man
well that is a very Vivid premonition
you were having yeah she has more Vivid
ones than Sawa did I must have lost
control because I crashed into a lake
and I drowned
remember the on-ramp there was a
pregnant woman in a white delivery there
yeah yeah
she gives birth to a baby that would
have died in that car crash if there's
the whole list out of whack and we start
over with a clean slate seems like a bit
of a reach don't you think whole thing
is a reach never came to the station we
had to find her we have to warning about
the lake so she can stay alive long
enough to have the baby
and then we don't care what happens to
her vehicle's a delivery van registered
to Marcus and Isabella Hudson the acting
in this feels like it's out of a b movie
this time around too I still cannot
believe that you predicted Highway to
Hell I'm still on that dude man that's
what I'm here for hey let go my show
is that dog [__] dude
he's the worst oh you got something on
there
where it's still there bro yeah I can
get a fight no oh my God what I don't
even see what he has I think he's just
messing what
bizarre scene you're so weird what
you're saying is true that means I'm
next first death is stalking us and now
premonitions is what these were all
together why don't you just pay
attention to what happened at flight 8
180 and then realize it's happening
right now trying to make us all crazy
[Applause]
this
darling that is pure coincidence we need
to look out for each other from now on
sleeping shifts we need to save proof
this death trap I think clear should
have been the lead of this movie yeah me
too
she's easily the best performer I think
that they're all good but we just like
her best this vehicle's been reported
stolen nice
I think everyone's fine
I think there's a lack of chemistry
still but everyone is fine as an
individual performer four years ago my
husband died
two minutes there's nothing left for me
it's not true honey
if we just stick together long enough
for her to have her baby you know if you
excuse me I have a funeral to plan that
was one of my big criticisms of the last
one is they didn't seem to have they
didn't seem to care when someone died so
I appreciate it sir maybe it'll scare
these people but I'm not buying that
[__] be careful man even if you don't
believe
give this to Nora
why would he be able to give it to Nora
you know sometimes you just just like go
catch up to her go with the flow on the
any illogical things
wow that is room for disaster
oh
move
why are you doing that
[Music]
why did he do that what if you could
just get so much like anxiety and you
attract what you fear then you could
just accidentally caused some of the
stuff to happen to you you know or you
have a heart attack
have a heart attack from the stress yeah
it's important to relax
oh he sees it
man with hooks oh he sees it in the
elevator it's funny that like death Rats
on itself gotta give it a chance
people are just uh creepy as hell oh my
God
what
I can't hear you what what what is it
what a man with hooks is gonna kill you
Saturday is so funny
[Music]
stay still
cut your hair off
[Music]
oh they did establish those are hard to
open
[Music]
scalper
is it gonna scalp her
[Music]
where they push her in what are you guys
doing
[Music]
oh God that's disturbing
bummer
I think he believes now they found the
van Isabel is being held at the
Greenwood Lake sheriff station
this is not the way this is supposed to
go give me the gun Eugene no no no no no
no no no usually don't do it don't do it
[Music]
but he's not next you don't keep it
loaded
you're all Duds six in a row it wasn't
his turn to die that's so interesting we
find the pregnant woman now please they
both look like Rory from Gilmore Girls
it's not your turn to die I would live
it the [__] up like jump off every
building yeah let's put this to the
tests
and I get out of here I'm going to
really
oh no no no oh that's why they give a
car goes in the lake you gotta deliver
the baby my water it just broke I'm
gonna have my baby no you can't do this
to me don't just stand there get me to a
hospital just give me a second to think
um
second I think just
the most incapable person I've ever met
strawberry I need the car my van my van
take my take my van
yes take the van that you believe is
stolen
last year my partner and I were heading
out when A call came in about a train
wreck
he died that night in a shootout
if that call would come in just 10
seconds later
I'd be dead too we all cheat death let's
go start this cheesy little bed and
breakfast in Pennsylvania right there's
this major gas leak that no one knows
about and all the guests suffocated
during the night did the bus I was on
splattered some girl all over the road
was that money Abraham the bus that hit
the girl the bus you were on kill Terry
Chaney she was supposed to die on flight
180. do you guys remember that theater
in Paris that collapsed last year and
killed everybody inside oh my God this
this dude
I know her just gets whacked by this
falling sign Carter the teacher I
replaced
him was Val Luton oh it's all connected
who are these people people got off of
flight 180
such a cool link I did not see that
coming that was good that was really
that was good Greg and I also feel like
the actors are forming more chemistry in
a natural way did you drive a little
faster
[Music]
oh no being alive after we were supposed
to die it caused an outward Ripple if
you had never gotten off the plane we
wouldn't be alive in the first place yes
that's why debt is working backwards
it's tying up all the Loose Ends ah
that kind of checks out yeah it's like
that butterfly effecting
oh
[Applause]
why aren't you hitting the break are
they the cause for why the baby goes
into the water
where are we is everybody all right
[Music]
I gotta go help those people do you want
to deliver this baby those people can
help let's go or at least call it in
yeah officer Adams reporting a vehicle
collision off 9A at the 180 mile marker
he is the worst he's not a good cop he's
not a good dude
[Music]
everyone okay
come on you're going to get me out of
here before this thing explodes there's
something okay
I think it's okay no
oh and look out for potholes and puddles
sir you can't come in Miss watch out for
power
I love her
jeez now he's part of it too every
person they save death is coming yeah
yeah it makes you pay attention all
these details now
oh no
gas leak that was a really cool shot
yeah poop
and if I die
um if you throwing all my drugs and my
paraphernalia my porno
his waden porno
it's gonna break my mom's heart maybe he
made the porno and my porno that I
started
it's the post credit scene final
thrustination no
Isabella's at Lakeview Hospital they're
prepping her for delivery we got it we
made it what about cats I'll go talk to
her why did they make it though go on
I'll be fine
could you be a little quieter with that
thing please what do you expect I'll
just put it on quiet mode
it'll be good
[Music]
yikes
God I would love to play dominoes with
death yeah it's like there's Rube
Goldberg
[Music]
foreign
no time to be in shock at all about it I
don't know why can't you breathe
[Music]
oh my God is that the baby's POV or
Isabella's uh why are they letting her
drive yeah I don't know I was in a
hospital I they were screaming and a
nurse was trying to choke me and I
couldn't I couldn't see her but I could
see her Nancy it was right in my face
the nurse was trying to choke me I think
a nurse named collage
why would the nurse try to kill Isabella
the chords around the neck this Baby's
in trouble ironically the woman was
impaled through the head after her
emergency airbag deployed and maybe
don't have the news on for
oh and so it begins I don't know about
the Order anymore
I think Dad just wants to clean up man
we may need to do a stat cesarean get
doctor Collision up here now Dr
Collision
elements
air it really is the elements that it
works with yeah
but why why is she gonna try to kill
this woman I have no clue there's got to
be something it's her husband's baby in
there
[Music]
oh no no down to 40. God what's up oh I
might have to kill her to save the baby
yeah but you wouldn't strangle her I
mean you gotta do what you gotta do
[Music]
I do like this cacophony of intercutting
between all the different ones
it's a boy
[Laughter]
wait is this the real finale I thought
this is gonna be like a 20 second
mislead yeah I think we're in trouble
don't worry she had the baby it's okay
it's over
it can't be that no no definitely not
promo time Kimberly
Isabella was never supposed to die in
that pileup what
she's pregnant herself
some bloody hands
Gene I don't understand what's happening
it wasn't the life of her because she
wasn't gonna die anyway it was somebody
else's life
[Music]
no
oh Claire
that's all you're clear would die
you guys have to have sex and make a
baby
it took nine months though right yes I
don't know
bloody hands you're pregnant
Lake
what's happening put it together faster
New Life
I have to die you can't give up now we
have to fight this thing
how is you dying New Life
could get collagen I have no idea what's
happening okay I have no clue yeah
[Music]
also who are you trying to save anymore
him just him it's worth it man
if your dad say bye like
[Music]
did she have to drive it into the lake
sir premonition yeah but what was the
get collage in part
um I I guess we have to well it'll
unfold
[Music]
this at a really beautiful place my God
in Canada apparently Canada is a very
beautiful place
didn't you have that drug dealer's Keys
you're supposed to go clear out his
porno I guess he wasn't a dealer he was
a user yeah it's fair
I think it's hard to break glass
underwater in a movie it's easier
I don't know I was wrong only New Life
can defeat death
if it is
what's the new life I don't get what her
thought process is here I think she
saves her she doesn't kill her the
doctor
right but what's new life this is her
like coming back to life yeah I think
she had to die and then come back yeah
she's back yeah epinephrine two
milligrams figure it out
seconds before yeah yeah I guess but the
Strangling and the new life I think she
misinterpreted it thinking that she was
being strangled but it wasn't
strangulation we lost you for a minute
okay yeah
we did it thanks to you we cheated death
but if she got that premonition wouldn't
death have anticipated this
[Music]
all right
Sun Shines on a new day this is really
great Mrs Gibbons
so how are you doing Kimberly
had a fun summer
fun Brian I think you better go check
that barbecue well Brian was almost hit
by that news van that day in the field
and your friend Rory he um he pulled him
back at the last second here we go
um
hell yeah
sweet sauce
okay so different kind of ending
interesting what what's your initial
reaction to that
the ending or the movie the ending
I'm glad it didn't repeat itself where
they just die at the end
but is your interpretation that because
he got saved that's why he died and that
the two of them are in the clear or they
she cheated death but he didn't like
what do you yeah I think they broke the
cycle but death
moved
you guys clarified
I think I think they broke the cycle but
death has
ah [__] you're right now now it's
messing with my head you know what I
mean yeah it is because they saved him
the rules are surprisingly confusing
when they don't when I feel like they
shouldn't be confusing or are we just
confused I don't know if they're as much
confusing as it's like they make up
rules as they go which is totally fine
because it makes for the movie to be so
fun but I am thinking if they say
Canadian casting
does that make you think they shot in
Canada why else would they what it's
Canadian casting maybe they're just like
nice people it totally looks like a
movie shot in Canada I believed you I
told you I thought you were right yep
good call uh okay so what do you think
go first
I thought that was really good like I I
I think I liked it better than the first
one but I because we already knew the
premise going in I think this one had a
harder task
and that's why I think I liked it better
because I think it had to do more work
to get me on board and it did take me a
little longer I'm bummed that clear is
dead I kind of wish she carried us
through the franchise I still don't feel
confident that saw was dead I feel like
he's popping up again some like late
much later sequel yeah I mean there's
five of them right
if I'm not mistake yeah and I think
they're working on a sixth right yeah
and we didn't see his body we just saw
that one photo and I feel I don't know
but yeah I wonder if Sava wanted to come
or they wanted him to come back and then
he didn't come back and then so they
just killed him off why do you want me
to go first are you nervous about your
thoughts on it
I just want to get my thoughts together
okay what's Your Gut what's your initial
like do you feel like between one and
two do you feel like you have a strong
oh I think I think for sure there's
things about this I like more and
there's for sure things I like more
about the first one this one was icky
you're like the dentist stuff that
freaked me out the kills in this were so
much uh more intense which I love yeah
me too me too but you and I both were
really connected to the characters in
the first one yeah I I wasn't like
massively in love with the characters in
the first one but I definitely cared
more and I thought the especially for
our lead character that was much more
interesting I think that the I think the
directing of the first movie had a
sharper
direct I think is sharper it was a
sharper craftsmanship I would say in in
terms of the working with the
cinematographer and the overall yes
no I now it's confirmed
before we weren't 100 confident
um yeah the the
cinematographer uh of the cinematography
the first one I thought was a little bit
sharper and I thought the first one had
a better grip on tension but
the funny part is I in if I'm not
mistaken what I said in the last movie
was I thought in the first half it
started to lose some of I thought in the
last half of the first movie it started
to lose some of its Steam and this one
you thought picked up and I thought this
one actually maintained that fun
throughout and that excite that that
thing were because this has started off
like city of Vancouver just wanted to
keep taking credit for that so this this
started uh District of Campbell River
that's what I'm talking about baby yeah
um but when I'm so distracted by the
credits
this started off fun and I loved the
sequence on the freeway so much yeah
that was cool and it just you like that
better than the plane not that it's all
about a comparison but I'm just curious
I mean it's bound to be comparative yeah
this is direct connection it's tying
it's not just a soft reboot or some [__]
like it's directly connected to the
first one and it's a sequel so yeah I
think the highway sequence was just so
masterfully done and the the fun of this
did main like this feels so much like a
horror sequel in that sense so yeah we
just gotta kind of go bigger and crazier
um and I think that they captured that
element really well I still feel the
first one is probably a better movie
overall
uh but this is more of the thing I you
know your audience kind of shows up for
because I was I didn't really find this
one like suspenseful or as like fun of
an Intrigue but then again like you were
saying it because it's a part two you're
kind of aware of some of those things
like I thought the Intrigue Factor kind
of went down that I would find myself
just waiting for like death stuff to
happen and I and I the characters were
nowhere near as Charming as the first
one so like I said there's things about
this one that I think are just so so
much better and so much more fun and
exciting and then maintains that energy
but the the first movie I thought just
had a better it was a little more
gripping I would say you know I thought
that the reveal in this one that this
was connected how this was connected to
that one yeah was like a turning point
in the movie for me where I was like oh
that's super smart what they did here
yeah that's why at the ending I'm still
trying to kind of connect with it
because it's like okay so the premise
being that if you cheat death it doesn't
just affect your life it affects other
people's lives who also then cheat death
because they would have been dead too
but you ended up saving their life in
some kind of a way right that's what we
were taught I'm pretty sure yeah and so
then that's what we're taught with that
guy at the end
um basically that same kind of thing
happened and then he wasn't able to
cheat it so I am still kind of curious
moving forward in this franchise how
that
how those rules play but I really when
we had that scene in the car and they're
all going around about how they all have
treated death and and connecting the
dots I was like oh yeah this movie did
it like it was that aha moment that I
was waiting for uh that I just thought
that they totally nailed and I did I
liked our protagonist I thought she was
good I liked the uh the sentence I don't
always say I liked the cop
I thought he was a good character too I
like the two of their Dynamic I don't
know if they were kind of like in the
last one couldn't tell if they were
flirting
couldn't tell if we were supposed to be
rooting for them I wonder if there's
gonna end one of these be like a
full-blown love story she kind of kisses
him on the cheek at the end when she was
supposed to and I was like I could
honestly as lover love she worships I'd
go for make out I could yeah yeah like
you know you're about to die suck face
one last time uh but yeah that means I
thought they had chemistry so I think
that they did a really good job with
that too
I yeah what a franchise this is a good
good thriller franchise
yeah I think I think it's good that they
they came out alive at the end because
you they need to have something that
where they can defeat it otherwise what
a boring franchise this would be if if
it's just like all right they're all
gonna die because you can't beat this
you know you need to have something
where they can beat it that's a really
integral quality to I think a horror
movie like this or a thriller or
whatever I don't know what campus really
belongs to it's me it feels like a
horror movie it's about surviving death
on the thing that we rented it on it's
listed as frightening oh really okay
it's a thriller yeah so it's a horror
movie I would say that's accurate was
frightening the dentist scene
that had you on the edge of your seat I
I had to turn away something about and I
actually don't even mind the dentist but
something about
I I actually can't talk about it anymore
I'm sorry it says look at the Goosebumps
yeah this one had a a cell like I
thought the first one kind of lacked uh
a sort of self-awareness like it knew it
would have fun at times but this one's
self-awareness Factor was like through
the roof I thought when it came to the
scares and and the sequences too like
they really set out to just have more of
a of a fun adventure time it seems like
they were they they took notes off of
things that were like this is what
worked in the last one and let's really
make this work how many years apart were
they
um I guess it was 20 2003
let's find out let's find out
um yeah while you're looking for that
where you'll also tell me what I know
that guy from
which guy the cop
um he looks familiar to you he doesn't
look familiar to me at all definitely I
watch him on some show or something all
right let me look up some stuff here be
the best googler that Google's ever
Googled uh you really like the
characters I really didn't I I thought
that like I thought I liked her and him
I didn't love
um random girl I don't really like them
oh really I thought they were kind of
bland I liked them I liked them I liked
that because of what had happened he
believed her we were on board from the
jump I didn't love the girl it was smart
too that is a smart that's a good point
that's a really smart World building
thing I I didn't let the girl who was
the short uh brunette-haired girl with
the log on her lap yeah
um she didn't do much for me the drug
dude
um I was like I get it I wish that there
was a little more something there
um felt very cartoony yeah the guy that
took the gun I was like At first really
on board with him but then he changed
2000 and 2003 are the release dates okay
you kept feeling like it was like had
80s Vibes I didn't get that Center at
all it had major 2005s for me
um I felt especially because of costumes
I felt more of the this is like the the
way they approached this the switches
came out the way they approached how was
it did it go yeah with the little like
like uh yeah it wasn't leaking no it
wasn't you at the dentist uh this this
one had when I said 80s it meant it more
in how
like an 80 sequel often
feels and looks where
like the first one I thought had more
and I I could be wrong about this this
one felt like everything was shot closer
I felt like than the first movie of
things were a little bit more widescreen
and this was a little more standard and
maybe that's what I was creepier to me
and then um yeah perhaps and then the um
and just the overall I'm talking more
like the aura and vibe that this movie
sort of gave off where like all right
we're gonna go like we're gonna go a
little bit more crazy with the kills
here and the characters are gonna feel
more like
uh like just archetypes just like like
this guy's a druggie this person's this
this person like everything about it
read like an 80s screenplay but what
about the two main characters do they
read that way to you no no no I thought
they were just not that interesting
honestly they're a little vanilla yeah
whereas Dev and Sava and even the the
kind of like clears more interesting
here in some ways just because her
performance I think allows her to do
more like emoting and more intensity she
was like a completely different
character isn't that yeah at first when
she's like uh I don't know like
yeah uh so yeah change your hair change
your life Greg completely different
person
um and but in this one I gotta see that
guy you haven't told me I know I'm
trying I'm trying to multitask your
Michael you talking I'll look at him
because I know I know him a most popular
characters and and even like the music
choices here like a lot of the music
like when the on the lottery winner a
guy was dying they had this like oh yeah
I forgot about the rock music that was
going on here he's Jimmy Olsen and the
Lois and Clark series okay so I
definitely know him from that yeah he's
an angel has fallen loves soup okay so I
know from all these uh he's in uh uh I
have no idea what else he's been in oh
and the offer okay yeah there you go
super popular guy I knew him from a lot
he's 87 credits on IMDb so it works and
another thing I did like about it too is
that they did they oh yeah that was
great a great great kid death um was the
uh subversion of expectations on
like you think you're just getting to
the same setup or they're all in the car
okay these are our new cast of
characters who everyone is on this road
trip with them and then they all die
except for that I got that Central and a
jump though that's why I said to you
like oh you think that these two girls
are the main characters because I just
got the sunset they the the way that she
was just making such like
um
uh explicit comments at the top I was
like I don't think they're gonna keep
her that feels like the cast of
characters in that moment they felt like
80s characters to me like someone you'd
see it like Crystal Lake or something
like I'm gonna fry the 13th kind of
movie or nightmare or a Freddy movie in
my town There's a lake called Crystal
Lake what's Crystal Lake on the Friday
the 13th movies Jason Voorhees
oh my God I went to Crystal Lake growing
up oh that's a great sign for you
you're the one who had a premonition
about Highway to Hell that's what I'm
talking when they're on the highway and
uh they're escaping from Death that's
what I mean by its self-awareness it has
more of a like a tongue-in-cheek flair
to it that I really enjoyed what would
you want to see from the third one that
we didn't get in the first two a roller
coaster
I saw a roller coaster on the thumbnail
foreign
would you want more nuanced characters
uh yeah I mean it's not like a it's not
necessarily I'm craving you know like I
want this to be a character driven study
or something like that I I do think
though that it would behoove that or it
would benefit
from that in some way of it that only
adds to sort of the excitement and
intensity like sometimes when these
deaths are happening
they're just like
they don't even really seem to really
react to it after like for example when
that lady got killed in the van uh with
the airbag went off and stuff it was
like we used to go to the hospital now
of like someone just died granted
they're not really close with this
person so I kind of get it but that was
one of the things I had issue within the
first movie too was sometime like those
are people who knew each other and then
sometimes people would die and it
doesn't really seem like there's much of
any sort of real like oh my God I need a
process this no keep going well we did
get more of it this time like with the
guy who went to shoot himself you know
he witnessed her in the elevator and
then he was like like totally lost it
the mom with her son obviously that one
made a lot of sense that she was like if
it's my time to go it's my time to go
um that's a consistent thing I think
needs to kind of just carry over when
people are dying yeah I don't love I
actually really dug this I thought it
was excellent
I I know I made jokes about it
throughout I didn't love how angry
everybody was the whole time no this has
more of a cynical character approach
yeah yeah and I and it's okay to have
some characters that are angry all the
time but like I felt like all of them
were pissed at everybody the whole time
and it made it a slightly less fun for
me sometimes because I would like I you
know when the girl when Kimberly goes to
clear yeah I want to be able to relate
like you're in this horrible position
and you're going to somebody for help
but the way that she just comes in guns
a blazing and flips her off and I'm just
like I actually can't relate to you at
all anymore like you're being so mean
and vice versa with them um there's just
a few characters in this that I was like
oh this is cruel yeah it's just bizarre
how cruel you're being and some people
do get angry in these situations as they
these situations well no the thing is
they're they're playing the one note of
anger right and I feel because the first
movie was directed by James Wong oh yeah
uh which I'm remembering and he's done
some pretty great working horror uh
before he Anderson like I think he's
even working like American Horror Story
a bunch so uh their names James W you
might as well go into the horror realm
that is the way it goes man
um doll you James
so the the holy [__] sorry sorry sorry
damn you rush oh no what was I said the
director of this one versus the director
feel myself going I'm so sorry don't
lose yourself in this one versus the
director and that one with the anger
the anger feels um like like just okay
play the note of anger instead of but
there there has to be some kind of
um there's usually something underneath
anger right anger is usually the
secondary emotion of fear sadness yeah
and it doesn't ever feel like it's
something from some type of fear or
worry or some type of build up in this
movie it doesn't feel like they're like
projecting it or taking out something
but you know those words really coming
from sometimes it was just like
she's got to be angry so make her angry
make them angry because because in order
to make a like one of the things I think
happens a lot this is not the case here
but a lot of times when actors are like
forced to improvise in a scene or make
something up a lot of times actors will
resort to we gotta get angry to make it
seem like there's a conflict at hand
here like that's the most easiest go-to
emotion and sometimes that felt like it
feels like artificial and kind of
annoying here at times because Tony Todd
you guys were saying you guys are so mad
at Tony Todd he didn't do this bro like
you went in for help and you're like we
drove all this way can you please give
us the answers it's like he's a mere
mortal he's uh
he does also seem
obnoxiously mysterious to the [__] I
love Tony Todd's friends
he's so but he's it's like you obviously
know so much more yeah and you are
intentionally just like not giving them
[__] for some reason I don't know why he
doesn't give them anything it doesn't
bother me though because it's him for
some reason it's just working for me I I
cannot believe that it is 2023 and I
never saw this franchise with how much
this is up my alley like sure I love big
Ensemble casts I love Thrillers like
this I love the way that this is like
super 2000s to me
um and I love movies that keep me
guessing Non-Stop and this like even
when you guessed about the fish in the
mouth for the dentist or whatever
there's a million things going on right
there's the electricity there's the
water dripping there's the crows are
they gonna come in like I'm constantly
guessing because there's so many red
herrings and that's I love that in the
movie so I just can't believe that we
haven't seen this yet have you seen the
Saw movies
yeah oh wow oh so this should be nothing
for you I think I've I don't know if
I've seen all of them
um but I think I've seen a lot of them
they do the puzzles in the bathroom
right
they just do puzzles and bathrooms I'm
right right that's that movie
we got 100 pieces here we just gotta put
them together no no no it's like you're
stuck in the toilet and you have to get
yourself out yeah that's that franchisor
yeah
all of them you know I have a hard time
remembering sometimes with the movies
gosh Greg fine I have a hard time
remembering with the Takis sometimes I
don't know why movies don't how a movie
makes me feel stays with me but what
happens in the movie dude I'm the exact
same one because I'm such a TV Junkie
too it's just you know ask me what
happened in this movie in a year and
I'll be like I have no idea on the exact
same way I'm the exact same way I just
watched Despicable Me but I am right
about the toilet thing yeah yeah it's
all about toilet secret it's a comedy
it's a jigsaw's a plumber
what happened to Despicable Me I haven't
seen that oh I thought like I remember
oh you haven't seen it oh damn
um I won't say that uh anyway yeah I
think we is that the Minions movie uh
it's the first one of it yeah pretty
much okay yeah I haven't seen that okay
any other thoughts on uh would we watch
yeah I mean we I I don't I don't know
what I think I think which one is the
one in the comments there was even even
the producer uh Craig Perry four is
supposed to not be good that's what
everyone says and they're saying and
that makes me want to watch it so bad we
gotta get there you say it's bad I'm
like it sounds so fun there is only one
way for us to get there though
and that's what you guys liking
commenting watching the sharing with
your friends making sure that you're
going for a joke right the Final
Destination I tell you I was like what
you gonna say because I can't fill in
the blinker you know it's a fact uh you
guys if you like this video we'll keep
doing the Final Destination movies
that's how it works yeah that's how it
goes it wasn't a joke it's the only way
to operate around here man solid Truth
uh in order to get our to our final
destination I think that's what they
said about the fourth one right the
fourth one is the Final Destination or
something like the Batman but then it's
not actually is that what they start
doing I think something along those
lines I don't know this has no subtitle
right it's just Final Destination too I
love the the cover of the third one
though the roller coaster I didn't see
it and you did oh yeah I mean you were
gonna see that when we when we watch it
so I was like true or false roller
coaster of Love plays
I'm having a premonition roller coaster
and that's why we're not singers okay
thanks guys for joining us on this Final
Destination
uh
sure yeah yeah keep filling in the
silence
all right I'll do it in song I'll do it
all night long
keep it going it got weird when I did
that uh my final destination today is
going to be to give the biggest baddest
shout outest shout out to the patron of
the day
who is none other than
one
oh I choose
sure
Kevin's smart oh I was hoping you'd say
Kevin's smart why because being from
Boston it's the best to say smart
smart yeah he's wicked spot he's Kevin
smart can you give him a Boston shout
out he also it's like mixing Kevin
Garnett and Marcus Smart two previous
Celtics players Kevin smart nothing
better than when you're Wicked smack
Kevin I'm just so happy that you're here
with us and that's your Patron and that
you're watching these videos with us and
that you love Greg and maybe you love me
we don't know
oh that's good right that was good
stoked on it it was like can you say my
name normal dog no man that sounds great
yeah it's a uh the least sexy accent in
America Boston how about this let's try
this out can we do an acronym for Kevin
but make every letter for him
something from Boston okay
is for kelly green like the green
monster oh my God this is working e is
for
um
evil like how people think massholes are
V is for Vineyard Vines oh [__] which is
starting Martha's Vineyard part of
Massachusetts I is for I see you Kevin
you Wicked spot
um
n is for Newton which is where I'm from
in Massachusetts oh dude you did it oh I
thought you're gonna make me do the
whole name that's just Kevin yeah oh
good I kind of nailed that kind of you
full-heartedly bucket
just like you Kevin smart
oh thanks dude man appreciate you
okay bye
foreign